We have taken fish
out of the ocean
faster than they can reproduce.
Ninety percent
of the large fish,
like the tuna and the sharks,
are gone.
And we killed them in the
last 100 years alone.
Right now about a third
of the fisheries
of the world have collapsed.
If we continue like this,
before 2080
most of the fisheries of the
world will have collapsed.
Not only do we take fish
out of the ocean
faster than they can reproduce,
but, also, we are doing it
in a very destructive way.
These are trawlers,
shrimp trawlers,
in the South China Sea.
You can see their tracks
from a satellite photo.
In some places, for every pound
of shrimp that is caught,
ten pounds of other animals,
including fish,
starfish or corals,
are killed
and discarded overboard.
And on top of that,
we have pollution,
and now, every year,
eight million tons of plastic
enters the ocean.
And on top of that we have
climate change, global warming,
which is making the ocean
warmer and more acidic,
which is killing
coral reefs everywhere.
This used to be a coral reef
now this is a ghost
of a coral reef,
dead broken coral
overgrown by seaweed and slime.
So, in 2008,
I moved to Washington,
and we started by
asking questions.
The main question was:
"Are there pristine places
left in the ocean?"
So, we found this place in the
middle of the Pacific Ocean.
The Line Islands.
Seven of these islands
are uninhabited.
And off we went for five weeks
to places like this.
Millennium Atoll.
This is the size of Manhattan,
that belongs to Kiribati.
And as soon as we jump
in the water,
this is what we see.
Not only we saw healthy reefs,
but lots of predators.
Lots of predators.
( audience laughter )
You know, you jump in the water
and as soon as
your bubbles clear,
you are surrounded
by 10-12 sharks.
If you go to the African plains,
to the Serengeti,
you know,
you would expect to see
hundreds of thousands
of wildebeest,
and zebras, and antelopes,
and all the animals that
eat the grass.
The herbivores.
And then just a few thousand
or a few hundred lions, right?
This is what we thought
would happen on the reef.
This is what we learned
in school.
This is what we found
in textbooks.
But when we went to a pristine
reef for the first time,
we discovered then what we
thought was natural was not.
That biomass pyramid
is upside down.
You go to one of
these pristine reefs
and more than half of
most of the biomass,
more than half of
the biomass of fish,
is accounted for by
the top predators.
The big guys on top
of the food chain.
But then we went to a reef
with 5,000 people nearby
and this is what we saw.
Dead coral, no fish.
Only 5,000 people
were able to do this.
Now, the question now is:
"How many people are enough
to turn something pristine
into something that is not?"
So, we decided to go to a place
with less people
and test that question.
So, we went to the
most extreme place.
Pitcairn Island.
Fifty-two people live
on Pitcairn Island.
It belongs to the UK.
Pitcairn is inhabited
by 52 people.
The other three islands
are uninhabited.
We jump in the water and...
the visibility
was extraordinary,
but there are no fish.
There were some fish
but no sharks,
no groupers,
no snappers.
And then, we had to do it.
We had to go to these
places without people
and see what we find.
So, we went to places like this.
Henderson Atoll.
And we jump in the water
and the coral reefs were really,
really, really healthy.
Spectacular...
And of course, lots of sharks.
The same thing we found on the
Line Islands we found here.
This inverted biomass pyramid.
The place where
the predators dominate.
So, there you go,
that was our question answered.
Even 52 people,
a population as small as 52,
are able, over time, using just
traditional fishing methods
are enough to turn
something pristine
into something that is not.
The corals were fine,
they didn't have the impact
that the 5,000 Polynesians
had on that reef,
but they were able to remove,
over time,
all these large fish that
previously inhabited the reef.